uh do you follow American Sports I love
that you hated this yes I follow it I
like your basketball your hoops and your
swishes you love basketball and I made
your dream come true once you did you
let me meet a very nice man named
Charles Barkley yes I was we were in a
bar together we were yeah and we were in
Atlanta Y and uh suddenly I hear a
gentleman call my name and it's none
other than one of the great basketball
players all time yes yes uh Charles
Barkley and I happen to know that you
were a massive fan of the 1980s NBA oh
yes all you could see on VHS tapes when
uh when you were living in Germany yeah
up to 93 so the last thing I saw was the
sons Bulls finals featuring Charles
Barkley Dan Molly Michael Jon and Scotty
Pippen right and then you had no
knowledge of anything that happened in
the world after that oh it's like that
uh Will Smith Men in Black pen was just
show to my face in 1994 yeah so you knew
nothing so I remember bringing you over
and introducing you to Charles Barkley
and you uh you were just just filled
with wondrous Joy yes giggled he didn't
understand a word you said zero words we
he did not make eye contact with me he
could see the excitement was too high
for just a meeting of a man Al the fanny
pack I think was you wearing a really
bizarre European fanny pack Sparkles and
you got nervous and you went into I
think complete German I did and I I also
misremembered he's he went to alurn but
I said Alabama and this is a big no no
you pissed him off but he was a
gentleman he was a real gentleman about
it and he gave me and security a signal
and then we got you out of there you
carried me away I felt like I had won a
championship that was nice yes thank you
again Conan for this I have still yet to
repay you for this please I you know
maybe someday you'll introduce me to one
one of my Heroes and please list those
Heroes for me now all you'll need is a
mirror I love
myself yeah yeah H notes
yeah that'll cost us yeah we just lost
how many subscribers yeah uh it says
right here we fast moving number no no
no we just lost the better help people
oh we lost Casper mattresses what about
uh ZIP recruiter we gained du lingo
Dingo and Babel want in B in Rosetta
Stone Rosetta Stone wants in all of them
want people to learn how to speak
correct
German so in way we're winning yeah yeah
this is very exciting yeah um do you uh
do you have big plans for the coming
year you know yes I plan to go on tour
and learn how comedy functions and then
I will prepare a 60-minute presentation
of it so you're going to go on tour to
learn how Comedy Works you know how they
say if you want to land on the ground
jump out of a plane and then build your
parachute okay um I am going to here's
what I'm going to do I'm going to sign
you up for a six- week course where they
teach you please common aphorisms yes
okay yeah and you can learn them you can
learn because you don't seem to know the
simple things you know like you have to
cherish those the Journey of a Thousand
Miles starts with a with a shoes
hopefully if it's that
long when life gives you lemons make oh
throw those away and purchase limes as
they are
better more more more help me here I got
to come up with more a stitching time is
worth uh 42 cents okay
when at first you don't succeed oh give
it up immediately the early bird gets uh
probably eaten by the even earlier bird
yes who is usually larger yeah the
larger Birds usually get up earlier
larger birds and they lie on the ground
with their mouths open waiting yeah and
then they just yeah they wait for the
the early bird to land and then get
chewed yeah um you are uh like I say uh
you're like a vacuum yeah uh do you feel
that your intelligence is dropping in a
way I feel like my mind is expanding oh
I love that no I agree my mind is
expanding but my brain is shrinking
that's what happens after skull getting
bigger right I'm losing books smarts but
I'm gaining Cosmic like awareness you
know what I mean yeah I'm like Neil
delass Tyson yes okay um you get it it's
a reference to a canine who is less
intelligent than a scientist you know
what you're going to have to do a full
several things defecate uh probably
sleep also also also before you take
this Comedy Tour you must learn as a
comedian you're not supposed to say get
it over and over you know every time you
make a joke you shouldn't say get it how
do you not know you need to you just
have to hope they get it and if they
don't it's too bad but you can't keep
saying get so I will say like B oh look
at those donuts I hope you get it but if
you didn't get it that's too bad no
don't even say that don't bring up the
concept of getting it or not just be
confident that's all okay yeah that's a
very fun lesson to teach to me thank you
Cen listen some people people call me an
icon space cowboy space cowboy gang of
Gangster of Love you've got some theis
down you love American Music don't you I
love music and Americans make a lot of
it okay a lot a lot you make or
Americans just make a lot of oh sorry
it's just I've seen a lot of indictments
these days yes I I love all the musics I
love American Music very much Hall and
Oats is very nice Tech technotronic is
also very fun uh snap uh snap
exclamation point I got the power that's
an old one you like some old music I got
the
power but that's that's what is that
like 25 years old early 90s early 90s so
you're a creature really of the early
'90s I think so because we just didn't
receive many things after this I just
kind of turned my brains off and just
kept absorbing the same things I feel
like you got all the pop culture you
needed probably between 1986 and
1994 and then you said uh that's all I
need and and and you didn't no 1994
Dream Team 2 and then you move on and
then now I've watched Game of Thrones
six times in a row and this is the uh
this is the fullness of my experience
you think friends is a show that was on
for one season I assume friends is a
thing I would love to have some
of
okay